ما اعلنه السراج كان متوقعا فهو سيسلم
مهامه تلقائيا الى المجلس الرئاسي الجديد
الذي قد تتمخض عنه جولات الحوار المرتقبه
بين الاطراف الليبيه ليست استقاله وانما
هي استعداد لتسليم السلطه قبل نهايه
اكتوبر تشرين الاول المقبل بعد اعلان
السراج بساعات قال وزير الخارجيه التركي
مولود شاوش اوغلو ان مسؤولين من تركيا
وروسيا اقتربوا من اتفاق بشان وقف اطلاق
النار وعمليه سياسيه في ليبيا خلال
اجتماعات جرت بينهم اخيرا في انقره
الاسئله كثيره وان كان ابر زها اي تداعيات
لاعلان السراج سواء ما يتعلق
بافاقوس
ليم مهامي للسلطه تنفيد القادمه لقطه من
ليبيا
المنشوده يحدث ان يفكر مسؤول كبير في
الاستقاله وان يتاهب
لذلك الرجل الذي ارتبط اسمه بحكومه الوفاق
منذ اتفاق الخراط السياسي قد يتركها في
موعد اقصاه نهايه شهر اكتوبر المقبل كانما
وضع فائز السراج الجميعه امام
مسؤولياته سريعا خاض محللون في
الدواعي منهم من عز الامر الى خلافات
وانقسامات داخليه ومنهم من يشير الى ضغوط
اطراف خارجيه متدخله في الملف الليبي وثمه
ما يكتفي بالتذكير بتقارير اشارت الى ان
السراج ناقش مرارا خطه استقالته مع شركاء
دوليين اما الرجل نفسه فلا يخفي ان حكومته
لم تكن تعمل في ظروف طبيعيه بل وتعرضت لما
يدعوها مؤامرات داخليه وخارجيه الدولي لكن
ما يريده الان كما يقول هو ضمان انتقال
سلمي وسلس للسلطه ولذلك تجده يحث لجنه
الحوار الليبي على الاسراع بتشكيل سلطه
تنفيذيه جديده حتى يسلمها
مهامه السياق هنا لافت للنظر ولعله مما
يشجع السراج على الخروج من المشهد
فتصريحات تتزامن وحراك اقليميا ودوليا
لبلوره معالم تسويه سياسيه تطوي سني الحرب
والانقسام في
ليبيا الاجتماعات التركيه الروسيه في
انقره تبعها حديث عن الاقتراب من اتفاق
بشان وقف اطلاق النار في ليبيا وعمليه
سياس
هناك حتى الليبيون انفسهم قطعوا اشواط نحو
التوافق فحوار بوزنيقه في المغرب بين وفدي
المجلس الاعلى للدوله ومجلس النواب
المنعقد في طبرق احرز تقدما باتجاه
الاتفاق على اعاده تشكيل المجلس
الرئاسي وستبحث مشاورات الاسبوع المقبل
على الارجح ترتيبات ذلك واليات اختيار
حكومه وطنيه وتعيين اصحاب المناصب
السياديه مماثل ان لم يكن اكبر شهدته هذه
المدينه
السويسريه رحب السراج بالتوصيات المبدئيه
المنبثقه عن مشاورات مونترو الاخيره بين
الاطراف السياسيه الليبيه برعايه بعثه
الامم المتحده واهمها اعتماد مرحله
انتقاليه جديده مدتها 18 شهرا انها فتره
ستمهد الطريقه امام توحيد المؤسسات واجراء
انتخابات رئاسيه
وبرلمان فق قاعده
دستوريه رفعت الاجتماعات توصياتها تلك الى
الحوار الليبي الشامل المزمع عقده في جنيف
الشهر المقبل وجنيف كما يبدو مسار سياسي
اوسع واشمل ويبدو ان تصريحات السراج ستسرع
الخطى
نحوه مناقشه الموضوع ينضم الينا من مراطه
المحلل السياسي احمد الروياتي وعبر
الانترنت ابراهيم بلقاسم الك والمحلل
السياسي الليبي ومن الرباط بلال التليدي
الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل السياسي مرحبا بكم
جميعا سيد الروايات من مصراته كيف يفهم
اعلان السراج نيته بتسليم مهامه في نهايه
اكتوبر
المقبل تحياتي ط تحيات طيبه سي سيدتي لك
ولضيوفك الكرام للامانه هناك اكثر من
قراءه لهذا البيان الاخير للسيده السراج
ولكن على الاقل من ظاهر دباجه ما صدر منه
ما يظر انه بالفعل اصبح مستعد لتسليم
السلطه
ل للسلطات القادمه من بعده والتي وجه
رساله واضحه للجهات المعنيه بالتسويه
السياسيه بانه على استعداد لتسليم هذه
السلطه اذا ما تم
تشكيل مركز تنفيذي جديد في ليبيا بل انه
اكثر من ذلك اعتقد انه من خلال سياق
الحديث ما يؤكد بانه على بانه سيستقيل في
جميع الاحوال سواء كان استطاعت ال السلطات
او الجهات المعنيه بالتسويه السياسيه ان
تشكل هذا المجلس القادم او الرسم القادم
للشكل السياسي ليبي او لم تستطع وهنا ربما
اثارى حفيضه الكثيرين حول المخاوف من
الشغول السياسي في ليبيا وان كان في هذا
ايضا وجهد نض سنتطرق لها لاحقا ايضا هناك
من قال انه يحاول ان يفكك الضغط عن النفسه
في هذه الفتره بعد الضغوطات الكثيره
المشكله عليه والاتهامات التي وجهت اليه
بانه اصبح جزء من تعطيل المعادله السياسيه
الليبيه في فترات معينه وايضا هناك وبعض
المؤشرات تقول انه اصبح بالفعل تحت ضغوطات
كبيره وانه حتى حالته الصحيه لم تعد تسمح
وانه بالفعل اصبح مستعد لتسليم السلطه باي
شكل كان وانه يريد ان يسلمها بثلاثه
وبطريقه ديمقراطيه واخر نقطه ربما مهمه في
سياق حديثه تحديدا انه رمى بالكره في ملعب
الاطراف التي كانت تسوق بانه احد المعطلين
الرئيسيين لاي تسويه سياسيه وبالتالي هو
اليوم يقول لهم انا على استعداد لاي شكل
كان لاي تسويه لهذا التسليم فيرو ماذا
لديكم خ خ شهرين هل تستطيعون ان تخرجوا
مجلس رئاسي جديد وحكومه وفق الاتفاقيات
المبدئيه التي حصلت في جيف منذ اسبوع ام
لا هذا ربما هو المختصر
ا هذه الرؤيه لديك حول هذه النيه سيد
بلقاسم ماذا عن الشرق
الليبي هذا المعسكر المناوئ ل فايز السراج
ل طرابلس كيف يقرا مثل هذا التوجه لدى
رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله في ليبيا
تقصدي رئيس مجلس الرئاسي حقيقه اهلا بك او
في تقديري انه
يخر سيد بلقاسم السؤال للسيد
بلقاسم اهلا بك في البدايه واهلا بضيوفك
الكرام
الحقيقه انا لا ارى استقاله ولا ارى ان
المساله جديه هي فقط يعني تصريحات تقول
بانه سيسلم السلطه في حاله نجح الحوار
السياسي وانا اجزم بان السيد رئيس المجلس
الرئاسي متمسك با او يره او اعتقد انه في
تقديري يعني يتوقع فشل الحوار السياسي وما
زال يتشبث بخيار ان هذا الحوار لن يصل الى
تشكيل سلطه جديده وانه ما زال على امل على
ان ان يمدد لحكومه الوفاق الى مرحله جديده
بالرغم من كل المعطيات الموجوده امام الان
بان هذه الحكومه انتهت فعليا وانها يجب ان
تنتقل او تسلم السلطه لسلطه بعدها لانها
لن تستطيع التقديم اكثر م ما قدمته الانين
جئت بهذا اليقين سيد بلقاسم بانه يعني هي
عباره عن ط لان لان خذي المعطيات هذ هذه
هي المعطيات التي تجزم هذه المساله اولا
السيد رئيس المجلس الرئاسي كان موجود في
جينيف في الحوار الاخير الذي جار فقط قبل
قبل اقل من اسبوع بين فريق بين اعضاء من
الحوار السياسي وتواصل معهم والتقى ببعض
اعضاء الحوار السياسي او بعض اعضاء فريق
المسار السياسي فريق الحوار السياسي
برعايه الامم المتحده وتحاور معهم وحاول
نعهم بقبول مبادرته السياسيه التي يعني
احد ركائزها ان يتم تمديد عمر المجلس
الرئاسي وحكومه الوفاق الى مده زمنيه
محدده يجري في خلالها استفتاء على الدستور
ويكون مشرف على اجراء الانتخابات اثنين
تواصل رئيس المجلس الرئاسي مع عده دول في
محاوله اقناعها ان تدعمه في مشروع البقاء
مشروع مبادرتها السياسيه نحن امام
مبادرتين مبادره سلطه جديده وسلطه
انتقاليه جديده او مبادره التي طرحها
السيد السيد المستشار عجيله صالح وقدمها
للبعثه الام المتحده وهذه المبادره
السياسيه معنيه بتقسيم السلطه على مستوى
الاقاليم الثلاثه اختيار رئيس مجلس رئاسي
من اقليم ونائبه من اقليم اخر والثالث من
اقليم الاقليم الثالث وحكومه وحده وطنيه
منفصله عن المجلس الرئاسي ورئيس لحكومه
الوحده الوطنيه هذه الحكومه تكون مسؤوله
على مساله توحيد المؤسسات وانهاء حاله
الانقسام السياسي والاشراف على تقديم
خدمات سريعه ل المواطنين وان تكون هذه
الحكومه مسؤوله عن وضع قواعد دستوريه
لمرحله انتقاليه في خلال المرحله انتقاليه
الجديده تمهيدا للانتخابات العامه وتهيئ
الظروف لحاله الانتقال السلطه انتقال
السلمي لسلطه الى مرحل اكثر استقرارا يكون
اساسها الدستور بالدرجه الاولى الامر الذي
لم ينجح فيه ولن ينجح فيه المجلس الرئاسي
طيله مدته التي ظلت اربع سنوات دون ان
يقدم شيء خصوصا فيما يتعلق الدستور رغم
انه كان احد الشعارات التي وعد بها او احد
الشعارات التي رفعها منذ منذ وصوله للسلطه
ثلاثه وهذه مساله مهمه انه ارسل وفود
وارسل مستشارين الى كل الدول
المعنيه بالملف الليبي في محاوله اقناعهم
للوقوف مع حكومه الوفاق حتى تركيا الان
حتى تركيا الان الحليف الاساسي لحكومه
الوفاق تفكر جديا في من هي السلطه التي س
تخ هذه هذه السلطه سلطه حكومه والمجلس
الرئاسي واعتقد ان هذ كل محاولات الحوار
يعني ما تقول السيد بلقاسم سعود لهذه
الجدليه وهذه النقطه من التشكيك حاله
اليقين
بالنوايا في هذا الاعلان يعني ياسف كل ما
ما سياتي لاحقا من حوار في بوزنيقه وفي
سويسرا وفي جنيف اذهب لسيد تليدي سيد بلال
تليدي الى اي مدى يرتبط اعلان السراج
بالحوار في بوزنيقه هل احدهما نتيجه
الاخر الواقع ان الحوار الذي اجري في
بوزنيقه والذي استكمل ويستكمل كم في جنيف
ليس بينهما اي تعارض ويستطيع ان اقول بان
حوار بوزنيقه هو استئناف للبنات الاساسيه
والتفاهمات التي حصلت في بوزنيقه ان لم
نقل بان هناك نوع من التكامل في الاجنده
حوار بوزنيقه
تناول ما يرتبط بالمواقع القياديه في
الدوله في حين ان حوار جنيف يمضي الى
القضايا المرتبطه بالمجلس الرئاسي
والحكومه وترتيب الوضع الانتقالي انا في
اعتقادي ان تصريح السراج هو بالعكس بعكس
ما قاله الضيف الكريم هو اشاره ايجابيه
واشاره
طمانه للاطراف بان هناك جديه من طرف
المجلس الرئاسي في انجاح هذا الحوار وهذه
الاشاره الى الاستقاله هي فيها بعدين على
الاقل البعد الاول هو هذا الذي اشرت اليه
هو الطمان هو ان هناك جديه واراده للخروج
بحل سياسي والامر الثاني و وضع كل الاطراف
تحت طائله الضغط اي انه اذا لم تستطع ان
تحص ان تخرج بنتيجه ايجابيه وبحل سياسي
فليبيا سيكون مصيرها الفراغ وهو ما تخشاه
كل كل الاطراف لذلك سيدتي ليس هناك اي
تعارض بالبث والمطلق بين اجنده الحوار في
بوزنيقه وبين اجنده الحوار في جنيف ثم
اننا لا ينبغي ان ننسى بان الحوار في
بوزنيقه سيستكمل وان هناك تعهدا بالرجوع
مره ثانيه الى المغرب لاستكمال التفاصيل
المرتبطه بتوزيع او بتقسيم المواقع
القياديه المختلف حولها والان التي حصلت
فيها تفاهما لم تعد هناك الاين هذه
التفاهمات في بوزنيقه اذا تربط بينها وترى
بان هي نتيجه هذه
المفاوضات سيدي
رواياتي رايك بما قاله بتشكيك كبير في هذه
النوايا وذكر نقاط عده بالاضافه لان
رويترز نقلت عن طارق المجريسي هو باحث
سياسي في المجلس الاوروبي للعلاقات
الخارجيه قوله بان هي هذه هي فعليا ضربه
البدايه لجوله جديده من المناورات التي
لما
ستاتي بعد ذلك ما رايكم مثل هذه الكلام عن
اي مناورات
يتحدث اشكرك على اثاره هذا السؤال لانني
كنت ايضا ساعلق قليلا على اخي السيد بقاسم
انا لا اعرف لماذا هذا التحامل على المجلس
الرئاسي او على السيد السراج كونه ربما هو
يماطل اليوم او انه معطل يعني لا اعرف
الفكره من من تبرير هذا الموضوع بهذا
الشكل وهل السيد السراج في جميع الاحوال
حتى وان كان مناف ناس في العمليه السياسيه
او كان يحاول
جرجره المسارات السياسيه لما يخدم مصالحها
او الرؤيه التي هو يراها هل في هذا يعني
شيء يعني يعني خارج عن السياق الطبيعي
للاوضاع في جميع الاحوال او انه ماذا يعني
اذا ما قامت الاطراف الاخرى بعملها في
انتاج تسويه سياسيه قادمه هل السيد سراد
سيعطل هل هو من يعطل هذا المشروع لا اعتقد
ان السيد سراج يمثل الرقم المعطر في
القاعده بل العكس هو كما قال ضيفك من
الرباط هو اليوم اعطى بوادر الطم انا بانه
لن يتعنت في اي منتج كان ربما هو يحاول هو
وحاشيته ان يذهب بمسار التسفيه السياسيه
بما يختم مصالحه للبقاء فتره اطول لا شك
في ذلك وهذا حقه الشرعي كغيره من التيارات
السياسيه والشخصيات التي تريد ان تبقى في
المشهد وان يكون لها حصه من نصيب المرحله
القادمه ولكن لا لم يعطل كغيره من
الوزارات كما حصل مع التني عبان ما يعرف
باتفاق السلات الذي ابى ان يسلم وبقت
حكومه موازيه في المنطقه الشرقيه ايضا يجب
ان لا ننسى ان الرقم المعطر الحقيقي في
ليبيا دائما وابدا وسيظل حتى بعد التسفيه
ال القادمه هو حفتر او ما يعرف بمشروع
العسكري في المنطقه الشرقيه حتى الساعه لم
يتار في اي تسويه سياسيه نقاش هذا الموضوع
موضوع ما يعرف بالقياده العامه والجيش
لانه يظل دائما في المراحل السابقه هو من
افشل كل المشاريع السياسيه اما السيد
السراج اليوم لماذا نحمله فكره انه وكان
هناك شيئا وراء الاكمه ماذا تتوقع يعني
على الاقل هو اعطاك تصريح رسمي بانه سيسلم
لنفترض انه جاء التسويه سياسيه بعد شهر او
شهرين هو اليوم عبر عن هذا التسين بشري
بصريح العباره وامام الاعلام وامام الراي
العام العالمي الليبي هل سيتنر من هذا
الموضوع لا اعتقد اليوم الكره في ملعب
الاطراف السياسيه الاخرى اذا استطاعت
انتاج مشهد سياسي سيسلم لا شك في ذلك حفتر
ولكن ماذا على الاطراف الاخرى المعطله هل
سيتم احتوائها او تفكيكها او ادماجها ضمن
المشروع لتقتنع به مثل تيار الكرامه
بقياده حفتر او مثل التني او من سياتي من
بعده بعد ان استقال هو هذا السؤال المهم
يعني يعني ازاحه النظر عن الاشكالات
الحقيقيه
افش حتى وان كان فاشن والكل يعرف ان مرحله
السيرا سيد بقاسم سيد بقاسم
برايك الذي ما الذي ما هو المطلوب اذا
كانت النوايا تقدم من طرابلس بهذه الصوره
حتى وان شككت بها هي قدمت وهي طرحت في على
الطاوله واعلنت وهناك التزامات على الرجل
في كل الاحوال في حال التوصل لتسويات ماذا
عن الشرق الليبي هناك اسماء كبيره تعتبر
معطله مثل ما قال
السيد رواياتي من مصراته هناك اثني وهناك
ايضا حفتر وهو الرقم المعطل بحسب راي
رواياتي السيد مستشار عقيله صالح اجتمع
برئيس الحكومه الموازيه في شرق ليبيا عبد
الله تني وطلب منها الاستعداد لحل نفسها
بل هذه الحكومه استجابت سريعا اسرع من ما
هو مطلوب وقدمت استقالتها فعلا والان هذه
الحكومه تجهز لحل نفسها تدريجيا بناء على
توجيهات رئيس مجلس النواب المستشار عجيله
صالح والذي سيكون له دور مهم جدا في
المرحله الان انتقاليه القادمه اعتقد ان
المستشار عجيله صالح وهو صاحب المبادره
السياسيه التي نعمل من خلالها الان وال
التي تنال دعما دوليا واسعا وايضا هناك
تجاوب كبير من الاطراف في الداخل الليبي
اما مساله
الاجسام العسكريه او الامنيه او حتى
السياسيه المنخرط تحت مظله مجلس النواب
فهذه الاجسام باقيه في اطار هذه المظله
وفي اطار توجيهات رئيس مجلس النوا من
سيخرج من سيخرج عن هذا الاطار سيخرج عن
الشرعيه ويصبح جسما غير قانونيا وغير
شرعيا اما مساله هذا الطرف او ذاك منه
موجودين الان في السه ازاحه اسم مثل حفتر
وثني مرهون باول جلسه يعقدها مجلس النواب
دون استثناء اول جلسه يعقدها مجلس النواب
موحدا مجتمعا مهما كان هذه الاسماء سيزاع
كل هذه الاسماء الموجوده ولكن خلينا نرجع
نقطه سريعه انه انا لا اشكك في نوايا
المجلس الرئاسي بل المعطيات التي مقدمه
الان تجعلني لا اثق ابدا في في فيما يقال
الان انا اؤمن بخطوات جاده وحقيقيه لو قدم
رئيس مجلس
الرئاسي اسمع من سيد رواياتي تعليق سريع
على ما قلته سيد بلقاسم تفضل سيد رواياتي
سريعا نعم كنت اتمنى من السيد بجاسم ان
يتكلم باكثر واقعيه عندما يقول ان السيد
التني استقال بناء على توجيهات السيد عقيل
صالح هذا امر خاطئ هو استقال بناء على
الضغوطات الشعبيه التي حصلت في الشارع بل
العكس عجيله صالح تمسك به وقال له لا
تستقيل وابقى على سب على سبيل يعني تصريف
الاعمال ان صحت العباره ا انه لم يستقل
بناء على التوجيهات ايضا عندما يقول ان
القياده العسكريه لديهم او المؤسسه
العسكريه مندويه وتاخذ بتبعيتها واوامر من
البرلمان هذا طبعا شيء مضحك الكل يعرف ان
العمل العسكري حتى التي اطلقه على العاصمه
حفتر لم يستشر فيه عقيله صالح يعني يعني
يعني باي منطق يعني تحدثني عن دوله حققيه
غدي المعطل العنصر المعطل الحقيقي لاي
قضيه في ليبيا اولاي سياسه في ليبيا هو
حفتر وسيظل المعطل اذا لم
اذا لم يتم ترتيب سياسي حقيقي مع هذا مع
هذا المشروع مشروع ما يعرف بكرامه او حفتر
اما تقنعني بان هناك حكومه حقيقيه وتتبع
لعقيله صالح وحفتر يتبع صالح هذا كلام غير
منطقي سيد ارجوك يعني خلينا واقعين سيد
بقاسم يعني يعني حفتر يستشير ع سيد اليدي
كيف يتاثر المشهد والجهود الدبلوماسيه سيد
التليدي المغربيه في
بوزنيقه بما قاله
السراج قع ان اتصور ان الموقف المغربي
سيتلقى تصريحات السراج بكامل الارتياح لان
هذه التصريحات تدل على وجود اراده حقيقيه
للمضي الى ابعد مدى في الحل السياسي
المغرب يعرف بان الاطراف الموجوده الاطراف
الاقليميه وحتى بعض الاطراف الداخليه هي
في وضعيه ازمه ولا لا يمكن لها ان تمضي
بعيدا في اجواء الت وور كل يريد ان يخرج
الان بحل سياسي واعتقد بان هذه الاجنده
التي بدات في الرباط وستستت في جنيف
وسترجع الى الرباط
ستشكل ستشكل اجنده واحده متكامله تدرس كل
الابعاد نعم لدي لدي تخوف وقلق من ان تخرج
بعض الاطراف عن هذا المسار كما فعلت في
السابق خصوصا وان وان هناك بعض القوى
الاقليميه التي عبرت اكثر من مره عن ضيقها
باتفاق الصخيرات و وكل لوازمه الاخرى
ولذلك اتوقع انه اذا نجح
مسار الحوار في جنيف ثم في بوزنيقه في
جوله الثانيه فان هذا
سيعطي في في عجاله سيد التليدي ان موقع ما
يطبخ روسيا وتركيا ايضا مما يجري في
بوزنيقه وفي المشهد السياسي في
ليبيا انا اعتقد بان اتفاق الروسي التركي
هو مزدوج بعضه في سوريا وبعضه في ليبيا
واعتقد بان تركيا اليوم تبحث تشغل جمنه من
الاوراق هنا وهناك من اجل ان تضغط على على
على روسيا الا تعرقل مسار الحوار للتوصل
الى حل سياسي في ليبيا تركيا الان من م
صلحتها يتم ان يتوصل الفرقاء الى اتفاق
ومن مصلحتها ايضا ان يظهر بشكل واضح من هو
الطرف الذي يخرج عن الشرعيه والذي يعرقل
كل هذه الاتفاقات شكرا لك من الرباط بلال
التليدي الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
شكر الموصول ايضا للسيد ابراهيم بقاسم
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي الليبي ومن مراطه
للمحلل السياسي احمد
رواياتي ناتي الى ختام الحصاد الى
اللقاء
ن